happy pride this time i wanted to take a
look at that cluster of letters you'll
sometimes see together
i use the term lgbtq plus lesbian gay
bisexual trans
queer and then the plus is meant to be a
catch-all for any identity not covered
by those five letters
some people use the slightly longer
lgbtqia plus the i stands for intersex
the a can actually stand for a number of
things but one thing that i will see
people say that it stands for
it doesn't or at least it shouldn't and
that's ally
now the a can stand for agender asexual
or aromantic but the reason it should
not stand for ally is that
being an ally while that is deeply
appreciated and we desperately need as
many allies as we can get
that does not mean you get to insert
yourself into this community and claim
to be part of it
you would first of all be bumping out
those identities that i already named
that have more of a claim to that a
but more to the point being an ally and
not treating us like garbage and
fighting for our right to be human
that's the bare minimum you don't get a
prize for that